well detective Hayes could you tell us
in your timeline of events it was 7 1980
was just a case on her car
and I know it'd be my two kids supposed
to be home by 5:30 never arrived you're
almost out of clean nine
is this a hey don't you tell me about
will he's quiet
I don't think he got know as much
[Music]
I'm telling you and didn't run off all
you had to do was watch Madison look
around are you going where their beds
got no clip-on
looks like you haven't slept in a couple
days I'll never stop coming up with
theories about that case not job there's
no certainty
wait don't remember you don't know you
don't wait don't
did you think you could just go on and
never once absolute my old brains bunch
of missing pieces never been someplace
you couldn't leave you couldn't stay
both at the same time
things I've seen
things are no
people around this they're dead a lot of
people gone must be Grabill do whatever
you think you did or didn't do you know
deserve to suffer
it's just sorta like a thinker
[Music]
don't wanna know the whole story
you
you